hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game from last year's Global
chess League it's a game between Daniel
dubov and we and a lot of you guys have
been requesting this you you love how we
plays you love how duol plays so
naturally we want to see how how they
face off against each other and if you
remember uh some long long time ago when
I covered a game between Rashid ninov
and the for former World chess champion
tan petan uh we we said that it's kind
of a situation where an you know movable
object meets an Unstoppable Force but
here as they are both incredible
attackers it's sort of a uh like uh like
an Unstoppable Force meets an
Unstoppable Force now it's like I said
from the global chess League it's a team
event six players versus six players uh
and I imagine if it was um you know a
solo event that we would even have a
crazier game but for a team event this
I'm pretty sure you guys will love this
one so it's um uh every team has an icon
player on board one so obviously a very
strong player like danil here or or way
then they have two male players two
female players and one Junior player so
that's a little bit something about the
event uh now check out let's check out
this game it's a game from round two and
also right after this video I'm going to
show you uh the well a remage basically
with we having the white pieces danil
having the black pieces I think it's
from round seven of the event so let's
check it out it's a it's a wonderful
game uh danil with the white pieces
opens with Knight to F3 and uh to make
it even more interesting they will be
repeating the game Magnus Carlson and
Yanni pomi played in their game six of
the World Chess Championship match that
incredible one uh the first decisive
game of the World CH championship match
and the the longest ever to happen in
the world CH championship match but okay
this is a rapid game not a classical one
still it's very interesting that they
are you know uh deciding to debate this
uh at such quick format but okay Knight
F3 D5 uh G3 Knight to F6 and now Bishop
to G2 we have Pawn to E6 Castle and
Bishop to E7 uh we have Pawn to D4
castles and now c4 is what's usually
played But Here pawn to B3 sort of a
surprise but not really as the game is
incredibly famous we have Pawn to C5 de
captures Bishop captures and now Pawn to
C4 and here there are only two games
that reach this exact same position the
one that you are seeing now between
danil and we and game six of the world
CH championship match between Magnus
Carlson and Yan pish so here D captures
and C4 Queen to C2 and now Queen to E7
so repeating everything as as it
happened in the in the world CH
championship game Knight beat to D2
Knight to C6 and now Knight captures on
C4 and in that game Yanni poni played
Pawn to B5 now it's a very tricky move
as you open up this diagonal but if you
haven't seen game six of the world CH
championship match at first link in the
description below and there we discuss
it in quite some length I believe it's
like a 40 minute video uh but here we
played Pawn to E5 now what's interesting
here is that B5 Pawn to E5 and Bishop to
D7 are the top three moves recommended
by the engine so by playing E5 uh we is
sort of saying to danil I found an
improvement on this game or maybe not
Improvement but I definitely know what
I'm doing here uh but it's also
interesting what danil um has to say
about this because as you know he was
one of Magnus Carlson seconds during his
world CH championship match against
danani pishi so uh his knowledge about
this should be fairly fairly extensive
so let's check it out it is now as of
move 11 that we have a completely new
game uh Bishop to B2 okay just putting
more pressure on that E5 pawn pawn to E4
now attacking the Knight we have Knight
to G5 and Bishop to F5 defending on e4
but also you know in some lines maybe
bishop comes to G6 you want to push the
pawn to E3 attack the queen attack F2 so
those are the ideas so Knight to
E3 uh stopping the advancement and also
allowing the doubling of the pawns and
that's exactly what we goes for Bishop
captures as the bishop on C5 is attacked
so it might be sort of a problem to
leave it there you have to worry about
Bishop captures an F6 then you can't
capture with the queen because the
bishop hangs uh it's best to give up the
bishop Bishop captures on E3 F captures
on E3 and now just Bishop back to G6 so
here we did mess up um danil's Pawn
structure in front of the king but theil
will also do the same he has to decide
whether he wants to give up this strong
Bishop for the Knight uh to mess up um
we Pawn structure uh but as the engine
says it's the best thing to do we U
Daniel obviously decides correctly we
have captures on F6 G captures and now
Knight back to H3 so now both of them
with a fairly cracked defenses in front
of their King we have Knight B4 going
after the queen queen to B2 putting
pressure on the F6 pawn and now okay if
we wanted he could play uh some well uh
different moves he could play Maybe
Knight to D5 to defend F6 but he plays
Queen to E5 he offers a queen trade and
theil declines this we have Queen to D2
uh we have uh Pawn to A5 as the Knight
on B4 is hanging and now Rook 8 to D1
waiting for we to play Rook eight to d8
to give up his Queen for the two Rooks
but the we not interested in that he
plays Rook a to C8 uh Knight to F4 and
now uh King to
G7 uh we have Queen to D7 uh now putting
pressure on that B7 Pawn uh and Rook F
to d8 and now while you could still take
the two Rooks for the queen uh the
grabbing a pawn also isn't terrible so
that's what Daniel does Queen captures
on B7 uh Rook to B8 attacking the queen
and now Queen to A7 uh also you could go
for an in between a nice Vision to
Knight captur and G6 to go after the
black queen uh but that's uh basically
forcing a draw and as they they will
play one more game where Wei will have
the white pieces danil wants to to make
the most out of the white pieces but
just to give you an example Knight
captures H captures let's say queen
captures on e4 you grab the pawn here
now you could trade Rooks for example
Rook captures Rook captures and Knight
captures on A2 and you get this position
where white is up a pawn but after let's
say Queens get traded off and okay white
activates the Rook uh a knight to C3
okay the B3 Pawn is hanging D2 Pawn is
hanging it's not not not really an
advantage so uh you could go for that
but like I said he wants the a keep the
Queens on the board uh hopefully
hopefully make more out of this game
Knight back to C6 attacks the queen
defends the pawn and now Queen to A6
again attacks the Knight Knight back to
B4 uh and now Queen to C4 or or you go
back to A7 but he goes to C4 uh and now
Rook bat to C8 offering uh uh well not
not offering much but uh you could give
up the queen for two Rooks once again
and uh again you have to decide whether
to play Knight captures on G6 first
because because if you do then we go
into a similar line now let's say queen
captures on e4 again Queen captures
Bishop captures and Rook captures on D1
Rook captures and well uh we we already
discussed that okay white is up a pawn
but after Knight C3 it's not going to be
all that much it is a little bit
different The Rook isn't actively
attacking the the B Pawn but uh still
objectively it's it's equal uh but here
uh dubov does go for the the trade he
gives up the queen for the two Rooks
plays Rook captures on d8 and I think
preferred this line to the other one is
that uh the the reason to it being that
he will now get a passed pawn and now if
he can get the maybe The Rook to C1
start pushing the pawn he has uh he has
some winning chances and here way not in
a rush to capture the pawn here first
goes Queen to C5 stops the pawn attacks
the E3 Pawn also will bring the Knight
here the the d82 pawn can be dealt with
later on so here Pawn to H4 preparing
Pawn to H5 and now Knight to C2 just
going for a capture here so Rook to D5
forcing a capture with the queen and if
the Rook captur if the Knight captured
would be a bit more dangerous but now
way not in a rush he just goes back
Queen to A7 he still wants to capture
with the Knight here we have Rook F to
D1 uh and now Bishop to F5 a bishop to
F5 a very tricky move um the idea being
that if Rook captures the bishop here
you will now capture with the Knight on
E3 and attack The Rook but also threaten
some very nasty discoveries and now uh
well there's not much you can try even
if you play C5 to sort of lock log the
Queen off just Knight captures on F5 The
Rook is undefended so you're winning
back material regardless so here after
Bishop to F5 daniil finds the absolute
best move Knight to H5 check uh and now
King to H6 going after the Knight and
now Knight captures on F6 now uh I will
show another line uh Rook captures on F5
as it is uh again it's probably a draw
offering and daniil really did not want
to to draw this game the idea is that
after Knight captures on E3 forking the
two Rooks and threatening some nasty
discoveries you have Rook captures on F6
sacrificing the Knight and after King
captures Rook to B1 this is the tricky
move uh point being that after Knight to
G4 or or some Discovery you don't get to
win material because the Rook just
blocks the queen The Rook on B1 now will
defend the Rook on B6 and that's pretty
much it uh so what you will have to do
here is go something like Queen to D4 uh
but yeah maybe this was objective best
to go for because if you don't find
Queen to D4 here white is just winning
Queen to D4 is the only move to uh sort
of continue the game but still now Rook
to B5 will come with check Knight to F5
opens up a discovery King to H2 Queen
captures on F6 Bishop captures on e4 you
will now also win the Knight here and
after King H6 Rook captures an F5 uh
it's it's a game I mean white can still
win white has the the bishop The Rook
the pass Pawn but black has the queen
and the white king is not um EXT well
extremely safe but nether is is Black's
King so uh it was definitely the way to
go uh Duo played Knight captures on F6
also very much playable now comes Knight
captures on E3 again with with the fork
and with the very nasty discoveries from
the queen king to H2 just unpinning
giving up the Rook Knight captures on D5
and now C captures on D5 and now danil
is ready to start pushing his Pawn uh
King to G7 way wants to bring the king
closer to stop uh stop the pass Pawn
Knight to H5 with check as the Knight
here is hanging so Knight to F H5 with
check maybe Rook to F1 was a little bit
better but it's a rapid game so you
don't have all the time in the world
King back to H6 now Knight to F4 uh
Queen to E3 and now Pawn to
D6 Daniel starts pushing his pass Pawn
but luckily there is Bishop to D7 uh
Rook to D5 now putting pressure on the
A5 Pawn also with some ideas of maybe
Rook to H5 check Pawn to A4 and now Rook
to H5 check again uh probably best
course of action would be to go for Rook
Rook E5 Rook D7 but this is again a
pretty much a force to draw uh because
the only way to counter this is to go
after the the D6 pawn and then you just
repeat Rook D5 attacks the queen queen
back to E3 and you again threaten this
queen D4 and Rook D5 uh but like I said
rapid game so Rook to H5 check was
played uh we have King to G7 Rook to G5
check King to f8 and now Knight to D5
going after the black queen now Queen to
F2 and now Knight back to F4 you have to
defend your E2 pawn queen back to D4 and
now Rook to D5 chasing away the queen
queen to B4 and now Bishop to H3 finally
Daniel gets rid of the bishop on on D7
uh but look at this uh if you if you
capture on H3 which is the absolute best
move uh then okay King to A8 and after
D7 you will be able to block uh the pass
Pawn with the King as the E6 square is
covered by the pawn so this is what
should be played however uh he played
King to E8 right away and it kind of
makes sense you do want your king here
but now danil should go for Rook to E5
check which he doesn't if he goes Rook
to E5 check King to d8 and now Bishop
captures on D7 then everything um sort
of uh gets uh you know eliminated he
will also capture on H7 he will have a
pass H Pawn then and it's u a draw with
with uh a best play but here Bishop
captures and D7 was played right away
and now it's a little bit different you
don't have time for Rook E5 Rook to D7
check so King captures on D7 and now
Knights to H5 trying to kick away the
king from the D7 square and then start
advancing the pass pawn and danil also
had a very interesting Checkmate in mind
the problem is we prevents it Queen to
B2 going for the E2 Pawn King H3 Queen
captures on E2 and now Knight to F6 with
check King to d8 uh and now the problem
is you don't have time for Rook to E5 if
you had time for Rook to E5 then look at
the black king the black king is
completely boxed in Rook E5 Rook d8
would be Checkmate uh however if you
tried Rook to E5 then there's this very
nasty Queen F1 check King G4 and queen
captures an F6 and now there's nothing
more to be uh done here so Rook to F5
was played instead stopping Queen F1 Now
Pawn to E3 way he has all the Time in
the World to advance his Pawn because
there's just no good way for the Knight
or The Rook to kick the king away from
the d8 square uh Knight to G4 now comes
Queen to D1 making room for the pass
Pawn to start marching forward and now
the Knight has to be uh sacrificed for
the pawn Knight captures an E3 Queen to
H1 check King G4 only move Queen to E4
with check connecting with the Knight
nicely uh and now King to H5 but even
Queen to E6 not rushing it there's
always time to capture H but we also
created a little trick here if daniil
defends the Knight then he will deliver
checkmate with Queen to G6 so of course
daniil has to stop checkmate he plays
Rook G5 but now just Queen captures an
E3 uh Rook G7 now uh danil is completely
lost but of course uh both they both
have a little time on the clock he will
try his best eliminate these pawns and
try pushing the the king side pawns
Queen T E5 check King to H6 Queen to E6
check King captures on H7 Queen captures
on A2 where also creates a pass pawn and
now H5 we have Pawn to A3 H6 uh Queen to
E6 now and even Pawn to G4 a A2 Pawn to
G5 A1 Queen where he gets another queen
into the game and now even
D7 uh so what do you play here King
captures on D7 now G6 as the F Pawn is
now pinned uh but uh well you could
still of course mess up any game any
position can still get messed up but
it's very very hard way you just played
Queen captures and G7 with check H
captures and queen captures on G6 we
have King to G8 and now F6 and he was in
this position on move 66 that Daniel Duo
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here a few more moves
will be played if you go to f8 then K
Queen to8 is Checkmate and if you go to
h8 doesn't really matter just Queen H5
check uh you waste the move Force the
king to f8 and now again Queen T8 will
be
Checkmate uh so yeah uh really really
incredible game I know a lot of you were
saying that you would like to see a game
between dubo and we and there are Al
together they've played five games
across different time formats uh first
ever uh encounter was a classical game
uh these two last ones were Rapids so
we're going to check out the two of them
and yeah maybe if it was a you know
imagine if it was an event where you
don't play for the team where uh usually
when you play for your team you can't
play just anything if even if you want
to play aggressive attacking chess uh
you know if you lose like in 10 moves 20
moves then your team will be angry at
you but uh yeah I mean still they played
a very nice game uh but yeah if it was a
if it was a single event I'm pretty sure
it'd be an even crazier game so this is
the first game they played from round
two also we're going to check out the
game they played in round seven where we
had the white pieces and du had a chance
to at retaliation with the black pieces
so stay tuned for that should be coming
up fairly shortly uh so yeah that's the
game I hope you guys enjoyed it the way
ye defeated their preparation for the
World Chess Championship match if you
haven't seen the game game six of their
match first link in the description
below uh if you have you know a good for
you or or you can check it out again I
mean it is great game uh so yeah I would
like to thank Samuel King Gard tlan
Jeremy antios Carl Weinberg and David
gasparian for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions but also whatever else
happens in the Chess World uh so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your
day